aimé jacquet est heureux il plaisante
avec la presse la coupe du monde en
france après tout c'est dans deux ans
seulement il n'y a pas la pression de la
qualification et pourtant il faut faire
comprendre à tous joueurs médias publics
qu il se passe toujours quelque chose
dans l'équipe de france et que c'est
contre la turquie c'est à dire
maintenant que son plan de conquête de
la coupe du monde commence et c'est
innovation tenter quelque chose sans
détruire ce que ce qu'on a qu'on cible
celle qui est difficile et à partir du
tournoi de france
une base nouvelle et on recommence je
dirais le sprint pour allez aborder la
coupe du monde
problème numéro un comment surveiller
l'évolution de tous les tricolores
partir l'étranger espagne italie
angleterre allemagne avait on a des
joueurs qui sont d'allemagne pour le
billet aussi et bien nous essayons de
répartir le travail en changeant chaque
fois nos observations
c'est dire que c'est un regroupement
d'observation qui me permet à préférer
synthèse aimer le football français ne
résisterait pas à une deuxième vague de
départs vers l'étranger l'équipe de
france va t-elle en souffrir je me
propres à parce que nous on a vis-à-vis
de beaucoup de football une une avancée
exceptionnelle ses coûts on a mis en
place la formation une formation qui a
été tant décrié rappelez-vous mon dieu
qu'est-ce que j'ai pas entendu puis
maintenant subitement les mêmes répète
mais la formation heureusement preneur
dont le sol est si le football avait pas
eu cette formation peut-être qu'il irait
plus de football français à l'heure
actuelle problème numéro 2 les bons
attaquants sont rares en plus dugarry ou
et des quais murray sont blessés
l'offensive est bien le souci d'aimé
jacquet nous on veut des garçons qui
kayl kiki team qui ont envie d'aller la
surface de vérité
il sait qu'il faut les former c'est un
mental est là nous ne sommes penchés là
dessus mais aussi il faut tête peut-être
un petit peu patient parce que nous n'a
pas on a par moments des attitudes qui
sont complètement de contradictoire
il faut quand même être un petit peu
patient le poste est tellement tellement
dur et bien il faut être là dessus
peluches peut-être les entourer de d'une
communication spéciale on a montré nos
limites à l'euro maintenant on va
aborder
coupe du monde c'est un autre événement
c'est d'autres équipes c'est que des
équipes sud américaines qui ont de la
qualité l'argentine le brésil la
colombie
donc vous voyez c'est un autre challenge
donc on est très conscient qu'on a
encore beaucoup de choses à faire et
beaucoup de progression a réalisé
beaucoup de joueurs en europe des
calendriers parfois trop chargé et des
matches amicaux pour travailler aimé
jacquet l'a dit tout de suite j'ai une
situation sportive délicate à gérer
[Musique]